Ein amerikaner hat wirklich unglaubliches erlebt und überlebt er wurde sieben mal vom blitz getroffen
wie und wo er verletzt wurde jetzt in diesem video und noch mehr ziemlich vertrackt über blitze
lieben dank für euren kult vorschlag bei whatsapp und herzlich willkommen bei klicks um science-fiction
gibt täglich wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal unser passt kein video mehr okay let's go herzlich willkommen
Erst perfekt so entstehen witze weltweit gibt es jeden tag zwischen 10 und 30 millionen blitze umgerechnet also
100 blitze pro sekunde
davon schlagen allerdings nur etwa zehn prozent in den erdboden ein
unglaubliche 200.000 blitze lassen sich an starken gewitter tagen an deutschlands himmel zählen meistens in den monaten mai bis september denn dann treten
luftmassen aufeinander
die sehr
unterschiedliche temperaturen aufweisen in der gewitterwolke bewegen sich die eis und wasser teilchen auf und ab und die natürliche luft
elektrizität wird polarisiert die positive elektrische ladung befindet sich zunehmend im oberen teil der wolke
die negative ladung an ihrer unterseite
dieses elektrische spannungsfeld wird immer größer und entlädt sich
schließlich ja vergleichbar mit einem kurzschluss
der blitz wandert dann im
zickzack richtung boden kilometer weit dann kommen ihnen fang ladung entgegen die ihn in eine bestimmte richtung lenken
beispielsweise von einem hohen turm oder einer stromleitung beim einschlag entlädt sich ein gewaltiger strom und die luft wird auf
30.000 grad celsius selbst zweiter effekt nicht nur auf der erde gibt es blitze
nicht nur auf der erde sondern auch auf anderen planeten wie dem jupiter und dem saturn gibt es blitze
möglicherweise auch auf neptun venus und uranus die voraussetzung dafür ist dass der jeweilige
planet eine dichte atmosphäre hat schon in den 70er jahren registrierten instrumente der volta raumsonden blitze beim jupiter also
elektromagnetische strahlung in kilohertz frequenzbereich ähnlich wie bei uns auf der erde und auch ansonsten
sind sie den irdischen
blitzen ähnlicher als gedacht später gab es dann von der raumsonde galileo bilder von jupiter blitzen die
tausendfach stärker sein könnten als die auf der erde zudem kommen sie dort weitaus häufiger vor wie ein
forschungsteam erst in diesem jahr entdeckte im durchschnitt gibt es auf dem jupiter auf jedem quadratkilometer bis zu
30 blitze auf der erde sind es nur 6 im jahr auch die saturn witze
sind wohl nicht ohne das legen daten nahe die die raumsonde cassini empfang hatte demnach könnten die blitze dort bürger
millionenfach stärker sein als auf der erde dritter fact es gibt verschiedene arten von blitzen
es gibt tatsächlich nicht nur den einen blitz sondern verschiedene blitz arten unterschieden
werden sie zum einen nach der richtung des light straße und danach welche polarität die zur erde
transportierte ladung hat der blitz der am häufigsten vorkommt ist der wolke erde blitz etwa
90 prozent der blitzer auf der erde gehören in diese kategorie
hier gehen die
verästelungen des leids stress von der wolke aus der leitstrahl
wandert von der wolke aus auf den erdboden und trifft dort die fangen ladung je nachdem wie die polarität des
streits ist wird er dann entweder positiver wolke erde blitz genannt oder
negativer wolke erde blitz für perfekt diese blitz mythen sind totaler unsinn
wenn blitze am himmel zucken sollte man weder eichen noch buchen bäuml als schutz
aussuchen der alte spruch bereichen sollst du weichen buchen dort zu suchen wird also in die tonne denn bäume
sind gewöhnlich hoch und blitze suchen sich gerne hohe objekte also diese
einladung dabei ist es ihnen komplett egal um welche
baumart es sich dort gerade handelt auch der rat sich auf einem freien feld flach hinzulegen ist nicht der ultimative
tipp besser in eine mulde oder einen graben hocken die füße dicht beieinander halten und die beine mit den armen
umfassen doch bei gewitter mit blitz muss man nicht nur auch noch das handy ausschalten und schmuck braucht er auch nicht
auszuziehen denn beides zieht die blitze nicht an
regenschirme macht er dagegen besser zu wenn er unterwegs sagt schnell zum auto zurück denn der bildet einen sogenannten faradayschen
käfig und leitet den blitze außenrum ab cabrios oder autos mit viel kunststoff dagegen sind im vergleich dazu nicht
fünfter fängt das ist zu tun wenn dich der blitz trifft oder jemanden in seiner nähe nach schätzung von experten und expertinnen
passierte sehr selten dass ein mensch in deutschland von einem blitz getroffen wird
zwischen 50 und 100 fälle gibt es wohl pro jahr in den usa sind es
300 menschen die pro jahr vom blitz getroffen werden einer von zehn menschen stirbt an den folgen des blitzeinschlages
rekordhalter ist ein amerikanischer rangers element ist laut dem guinness buch der rekorde
unglaubliche
sieben mal von einem blitz getroffen worden und hat überlebt
verloren hat er allerdings beim ersten mal den nagel des großen zehs beim zweiten mal eine augenbraue
dann wurde seine linke schulter
verletzt dann verschmutzen die kopf und bein paare und beim sechsten mal gelang der blitz in den knöchel und beim siebten und vorletzten mal
verbrannte sein oberkörper
also
verbrennungen außerhalb am schlimmsten und oft auch tätig sind die direkten witz anschlage in den körper also wenn der blitz in den kopf einschlägt und
dann durch den gesamten körper zieht dann wird das elektrische leitungssystem des herzens durcheinander gebracht und es kommt zu herzrhythmusstörungen
auch die nervenzellen werden durch den elektrischen schlag angegriffen und der atem setzt aus das kann dann auch zum kreislaufstillstand führen
häufiger aber sind indirekt treffer wenn es beispielsweise in einen mast ein steckt und sich die
elektrizität über dem boden
ausbreitet auf dem sich menschen befinden wenn jemand in eurer nähe vom blitz getroffen wird leistet unbedingt erste hilfe und
ruft den notarzt den studien besagen dass blitz opfer große chancen haben sich wieder vom kreislauf stillstand zu erholen
denn der strom zieht zwar heftig durch den körper allerdings nur kurz
doch ein blitzschlag in die menschen körper kann auch noch weitere langfristige schäden mit sich ziehen zudem hinterlassen blitze oft auch sichtbare spuren wie
beispielsweise ein bestimmtes muster in der haut was sich ein brennt wie ein tattoo quasi ok
eine
schmerzhafte methode ein tattoo zu bekommen
ja wenn ihr dieses video spannend gefunden habt dann endet meine telefonnummer whatsapp dann bekommt ihr täglich vor allen anderen den link zum video
von mir persönlich
geschickt und ein kleines geschenk
zur begrüßung einfach hier draufklicken und darunter auch draufklicken
außergewöhnlicher weißer zwerg schießt energetische blitze eine ganz andere form von blick bis dann
bleibt dran